die schweiz gefordert und ich rechne
jetzt mal leuchtet es hat mir sehr am
anfang hat mir die umgangsformen wie man
miteinander redet hat mich sehr
beeindruckt mittlerweile nach 14 jahren
habe ich auch ein bisschen zu den
negativen aspekt von diesem auf den
ersten blick sehr respektvollen umgang
gesehen man sagt oft nicht was man denkt
und dadurch hat man vielleicht auch
nicht so eine chance oder es bleibt doch
immer eine gewisse distanz
gerade wird er dialekt filmvater jagd
mit oriana schrage in der hauptrolle
geschnitten
die 37 jährige spielt eine ambitionierte
headhunterin die feststellen muss dass
seine ausschweifende liebesnacht nicht
folgenlos geblieben ist da der erzeuger
ihren ansprüchen nicht genügt muss ein
adäquater vater her
es ist die erste große hauptrolle auf
schweizerdeutsch für jana steht dass ich
mit dem schaffen mit dem präzise sie und
ich weiß ausdrucken und in
schwyzerdütsch bin ich noch unsicher
aber ich probiere es im alltag sprecher
gemeinsam mit regisseurin rachel gründer
übt sie den erzählt ex des films obwohl
schweizerdeutsch verschlage eine art
fremdsprache ist hat sie die regisseurin
überzeugt und sich gegen schweizer
konkurrentinnen behauptet sicheren
sympathieträger es extrem wichtig für
den film wird die figur ihrer sache
gemacht wo zum teil ganz sympathisch
sind
sie hat es ja der charme sich an der top
sie gleichzeitig aber rangieren verführe
also sie hat sehr vieles mitbrachte und
hat mich im casting total überzeugt
schauspielen werden das wollte oriana
schrage schon als mädchen 1977 in israel
geboren wuchs sie als tochter einer
brasilianerin und eines deutschen in
brasilien und deutschland auf
bereits als sechsjährige spielt sie
leidenschaftlich theater neben der bühne
kommt später auch kleinere auftritte im
fernsehen und engagement als model zu
nach dem abitur bewirbt sie sich an
diversen schauspielschulen in
deutschland erfolglos
2001 versucht sie es schließlich hier in
zürich in einem workshop als traffic und
das hat geklappt und innerhalb von
monaten
vor neun jahren hatte oriana schrage die
schauspielschule abgeschlossen
in zürich ist sie geblieben sie ist
heimisch geworden in dieser stadt wo sie
mit mann und zwei kindern lebt
vor zwei jahren hat sie sich einbürgern
lassen entspannen und trifft immer liegt
sie schätzt es dass ihre kinder hier
aufwachsen alles so friedlich und kinder
könnten sich deshalb sehr frei bewegen
trotzdem wünschte sich manchmal dass
zürich etwas offener wie auch
unberechenbar
man hat das gefühl in zürich ist kann
alles passieren
es kann jederzeit etwas geschehen das
stimmt schon also eine gewisse auch hier
in der konsum ein bisschen vielleicht
gedeckelt nicht aus der reihe tanzen
vielleicht deshalb liebt sie den blick
über die dächer der stadt
der horizont ist weiter hier oben große
große wunsch für tweets dass man weniger
öffnet das neue was da passiert